today on the matt walsh show i'll
explain why no competent
responsible parent especially of young
children can vote democrat i just don't
see how it's possible also five
headlines including
california's attempts to tell their
residents how many family members they
can have over for thanksgiving
where on their property they can meet
with them and how long they can stay
together all of that
uh the california government thinks it
can it can tell its residents plus
our daily cancellation and much more all
of that coming up but first
let's talk about our good friends at
rockauto.com
with with the ever increasing number of
makes and models
it's now basically impossible to stock
all the parts you need in the
traditional
chain storefront so what's the point of
enduring
these seemingly intimidating questions
and everything while you wait
while the guy behind the counter orders
the parts on his computer
you know choosing the only brand his
warehouse happens to carry because
that's the only option you have
you have computers and phones with
access to rockauto.com so just go there
one reason to repair and maintain your
cars is to save money of course
um that you can then use for other
important things like mortgage or food
why would you choose to spend thirty
percent fifty percent a hundred percent
more sometimes for the exact same auto
parts
at a chain store or a new car dealership
the rockauto.com catalog is unique it's
extremely easy to navigate so easy that
even i can do it quickly
you can see all the parts available for
your vehicle you can choose the brands
the specifications the prices you prefer
you do all of that just a couple clicks
it's done best of all prices
rockauto.com
are always reliably low and they're the
same no matter who you are
so why spend up to twice as much for the
same parts there's no reason to go to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available
for your car or truck and remember to
write walsh in their how did you hear
about us box
so they know that uh i'm the one who
sent you there okay
the website pink news recently published
a video
of a young boy named cj who calls
himself
gender creative has decided that
quote gender is over and now enjoys the
distinction of being the youngest grand
marshal
in the history of gay pride parades
here's uh some of that video
watch are we yeah ready we're
ready for pride hi i'm cj duran i'm 13
years old and i'm gender creative
my gender identity is male and my gender
expression is female
i'm not i've been gender created my
whole life but this is just who i am
to me gender is over we don't really
need it like it's kind of unnecessary
i'm in middle school now but in my old
school elementary school i changed sop
wasn't separated between boys and girls
and i changed the dress code for 26
schools so it wasn't separated between
boys clothes and girls clothes
i am currently the youngest grand
marshal in pride history i was grand
marshal for oc pride
it was really magical it felt really
powerful and like a dream
and it's really cool to be kind of like
a leader
it's very important for young kids to
see that there's kids like them
so it's really awesome that i was able
to be the grand marshal and they can see
me and know that they're not alone
it's no surprise that young cj has
parents who quote
support him and by support we mean that
his parents have worked very hard to
inculcate
the confusion the lack of identity from
which the child currently suffers
a few years ago his dad marched with him
in a pride parade
there's a picture of that he's carrying
a sign that reads
my son wears dresses and makeup get over
it
it is one of the more demented forms of
child abuse to dress your son in girl
clothes
and then literally march him through the
street to show him off
like he's some sort of trophy but
this is this is how these types of
parents view their kids as trophies to
show off their own wokeness but this is
this is a type of child abuse
that we are supposed to accept more than
accept celebrate applaud even emulate
and it's a form of child abuse
categorically supported
and encouraged by one of the major
political parties in this country
what used to be the agenda of the fringe
radical
far-left lgbt movement has now become a
mainstream feature of the democrat party
platform
one of its most visible standard bearers
congresswoman alexandra casa cortez
recently promoted a charity
that helps children quote transition
into a new gender she also expressed her
approval
of uh this video which shows a drag
queen
performing for a two-year-old you can
see it right here
and look at the father there if you can
call him that a father i don't think he
really can but
bro he brought his two-year-old son to a
drag queen brunch
this is the democrat party this is what
the democrat party is there might not be
any video that better encapsulates
what the democrat party is a drag queen
dancing for a two-year-old
and this goes all the way to the top joe
biden at a town hall two weeks ago
endorsed
the idea that an eight-year-old male
might really be a girl
trapped in a boy's body every elected
democrat believes this now or pretends
to believe it
and intends to use the school system and
the media and hollywood
and whatever other tools that they have
at their disposal to brainwash you and
especially your child
into the same belief this is just one
area one extremely significant area
where the democrat party has positioned
itself
as a threat to children and families
it would be reason enough this alone for
any competent and loving parent to never
vote democrat
but as the infomercial salesman says
there's more much more this is after all
the most anti-child
anti-family political party in american
history the defund the police movement
is an integral part of their campaign to
make families less safe
less stable there's a reason why you
mostly
see a lot of young childless very stupid
people marching through the streets
with defund the police banners and signs
no parent
wants to live in a community without
police no family man when he's
considering relocating his family tries
to find a community where the police
have fewer resources less funding are
less likely to respond to emergencies
parents want police to be a phone call
away not social workers
the defund the police movement is
anti-family and so it's no surprise
to find it promoted by black lives
matter a group that has announced its
intentions to destabilize the nuclear
family
in the realm of education the attacks on
school choice the war on homeschooling
all of this comes from the democrat
party it wants your child
in his local public school nowhere else
or maybe not in it right now but in his
room
in zoom meetings with his public school
teachers wherever he is the point is
that
you ought to have fewer education
options and less of a say over what your
child is taught
that's the democrat party's perspective
the left is suspicious of families
jealous of the influence parents have
over their children and intends quite
explicitly
to interfere with undermine and finally
subvert that influence
from the perspective of a democrat your
child belongs
first and foremost to the state and all
of the most
essential work of child raising should
be done by the state it's the state's
job to mold
and shape your child and instill the
quote correct
values into his mind now some democrats
will say this outright others will be
more circumspect
but this is how almost all of them feel
if you're a parent of a boy the assault
is even worse the democrat party
believes that young boys especially
white
young white boys must be deprogrammed of
their toxic masculinity reshaped
into something more acceptable for our
enlightened society
in some cases as we've seen they seek to
literally turn boys into girls and they
do believe that such a thing is possible
in a literal sense
but for all boys the goal is to
demasculi
demasculinize to feminize and as i list
the
the you know the assaults on the the
family and
and children of course we haven't even
mentioned the fact
that the democrat party supports the
murder of children
at the earliest stages of life they
reject the idea that children at their
youngest ages
can make any legitimate moral claims for
themselves or have any right to exist
whatsoever democrats celebrate the
slaughter of 60 million children
and increasingly we hear democrats such
as the governor of virginia
advocating the murder of born infants as
well as unborn infants
as i said the modern democrat party is
the most anti-family
anti-child political party that has ever
existed in this country
i don't see how any parent who is
competent and informed and responsible
could possibly vote to put these people
in power
but those qualifiers unfortunately
competent informed responsible
excludes a large number of parents which
explains the democrat party's political
success
and why it remains a clear and present
danger to all families
and all children in this country
let's get to our five headlines
okay number one here from the daily wire
law enforcement officials in
philadelphia have reportedly launched an
investigation into a vehicle that was
discovered containing explosives and
suspicious items
which comes as the city is rocked by
left-wing anti-police riots and
widespread looting abc6 reported
action news has learned that police
recovered propane tanks torches and
possible dynamite sticks from this van
the bomb squad is on the scene at this
hour city officials say at least
200 businesses many of them already
struggling the missile pandemic
were the targets of massive looting
across the city over the last couple of
nights
to assist police an undetermined number
of pennsylvania national guard troops
will soon be arriving in the city well
we haven't seen them yet
uh or at least we hadn't seen through
the first two two nights of of rioting
we didn't see any national guard
um and very few police actually out
there too philadelphia mayor jim kenney
slammed those who were looting and
writing saying that the destruction of
property will not be allowed
it's already been allowed we just got
through 200 businesses that have been
targeted
we're not going to allow you people to
do what you've already done and continue
to do
we won't allow it um he said the looting
has taken place that takes place that
has taken place is distressing
and it's clear that many of these folks
are taking advantage of the situation
harming our businesses and communities
doing a great disservice to those who
want to protest the death of walter
wallace jr
well nobody's protesting the death of
walter wallace jr no one is concerned
about that
that's got nothing to do with anything
that's happening
nor should anyone be protesting it
because he was charging at police with a
knife
and so there's no injustice here there's
no moral outrage it's a sad thing
anytime someone dies
it's not a moral outrage though nothing
nothing illegal or unlawful or unjust
took place
and then he continues from there so he
he um he calls it distressing
great very coming down really hard on
them
this is very distressing i'm very
distressed by this
you know reading this it reminds you
actually
in some ways how amazing it really is
that the rioting has not for the most
part escalated so far
into larger scale terrorist attacks like
bombings
now this is all terrorism in my view
black lives matter domestic terrorist
organization
i think they would fit that
categorization to a to a t
but this is politically motivated
violence
and the leaders of black lives matter
the people out in the streets they're
they're pretty explicit about that if
you listen to them
but in terms of large-scale attacks like
bombings we haven't
seen that yet not yet
though it seems like from this it's
trending this way and i can tell you
that if more democrats are put
in power people who coddle these
domestic terrorists encourage them
give them room to destroy in the
immortal words of the former
mayor of baltimore we're going to see
that escalation
because bad guys they'll do whatever you
allow them to do
you sit back and let them loot they'll
loot
give them even more liberty to commit
crimes and more violent crimes
they'll do that too number two here's a
story from a few days ago that i haven't
had a chance to talk about
until now but i can't uh but i have to
talk about it i can't just
let this one be article in newsweek it
says ahead of thanksgiving next month
california governor gavin newsom and the
california department of public health
released new safety guidelines for all
private gatherings amid the ongoing
coven 19 pandemic
the new rules come with strict
restrictions that aim to help reduce the
risk of spreading infection
um and uh here's what the statement says
from the cdph the california department
of public health
gatherings are defined as social
situations that bring people together
from different households at the same
time in a single space or place
that's good thank you for defining
gatherings for us
all gatherings must include no more than
three households
including hosts and guests and must be
held outdoors
lasting for two hours or less the longer
the duration the risk of transmission
increases
gatherings that occur outdoors are
significantly safer than indoor
gatherings all gatherings must be held
outside
attendees may go inside to use restrooms
very merciful i thank you for that
they could be telling us to go just pee
in our in our in you know if you're
visiting your
your uh in-laws or something they could
tell you to go pee in the bushes
and but no they're allowing you to go
inside so thank you so much to our
benevolent rulers i
i am i am so grateful
uh so you maybe go going to use the
restroom the new rules state that
those at the gathering may remove their
face coverings briefly to eat or drink
as long as they stay at least six feet
away from everyone outside their own
household
and put their face covering back on as
soon as they are done with the activity
uh it also mentions that now that of
course no singing or shouting or any
other form of
loud communication will be allowed so
democrats in california
talk about talk about the war on family
i could have included this i was saving
it for here
um they are telling you how many of your
own
family members you can have at your home
where on your property you're allowed to
meet with them
how long you may be with them what you
may do
together while while you are with them
and also that you have to wear a mask
you can lift it up to take a drink but
make sure you're six feet away so
every time you want to take a drink you
have to run away from everybody lift up
your mask take the drink
and then go back this
is uh this is almost unbelievable
i i have to tell you when i first saw
this online i
i'm not even saying this to be funny i
really thought it might be a parody i
thought
because someone had screenshotted some
of the the stuff like some of the um
some of the passages from this article
and i think that's how i first saw it on
twitter and i i really thought it was
from babylon b
but no this is very real
uh and of course it goes without saying
should go without saying they have
absolutely no authority to do this at
all they have
no authority and no power no legitimate
power to tell you
uh how many family members you can have
at your own house
i mean the the california department of
public health
what the hell authority do you have to
make these decisions
for me and what i can do in my own home
number three if you needed more reasons
to not support the girl scouts
aside from the fact that their cookies
taste like graham crackers that have
been sitting in your grandmother's
pantry since 1987
aside from that here's another one the
girl scouts tweeted this yesterday a
note of congratulations to amy coney
barrett for becoming the fifth woman
appointed to the supreme court now
that's not the reason to not support
them that's fine
okay that's a you know very nonpartisan
it's a
tweet saying congratulations there's a
picture of all five women that have been
appointed to the supreme court and
that's it non-political non-partisan
fine
but leftists of course were upset about
this because any any positive
acknowledgement of amy coney barrett or
any other
conservative is verboten is anathema
heretical you can't do it they can't
stomach it they can't allow it so
they ganged up and bullied the girl
scouts into deleting
and essentially apologizing for this
post and saying that uh you know it was
a mistake to put it up because
they didn't want to be political they
weren't trying to be political they're a
non-political organization
but then shocker of shockers here girl
scouts have tweeted in the past
congratulating liberal female supreme
court justices
like sonia sotomayor and those tweets
are still up
so those apparently are not political it
becomes political all of a sudden
when you're congratulating a
conservative right so what are the girl
scouts teaching girls here what's the
lesson
they're teaching girls to cave to peer
pressure
back down to the mob apologize for doing
things that aren't wrong
just because it made someone's tummy
hurt and they complained about it
um and conformed to the crowd that's
that's what they're being taught
basically all of the exactly wrong sorts
of lessons
that's what you get from the girl scouts
number four i'm going to show you
something
speaking of things that seem like a joke
at first i'm going to show you this this
is 100
real i assure you uh but with no setup
here it is without context watch
as of today there have been 38 160 cases
of covid19 in oregon
with 390 new cases being reported today
sadly we are also reporting three deaths
today
bringing the statewide total for covet
19 related deaths
to 608
now for those listening to the podcast
the audio probably didn't sound too bad
you're probably listening to that thing
okay what's the problem
um it sounded like maybe some kind of
health official announcing
covid daily death numbers which is what
it was that's a senior official with the
oregon health
authority making this announcement about
coven
problem and what you can't see if you're
only listening is that the woman
is actually wearing clown makeup
she is dressed like a clown to tell us
who died from covid
this was apparently supposed to be some
sort of halloween thing okay
but that's not an excuse i mean just
because it's gonna be halloween
that doesn't mean you could just wear a
costume anytime you want
regardless of the circumstance how would
you feel if you were going in for heart
surgery
and your heart surgeon right before you
went under from the
the anesthesia you see your heart
surgeon coming in
dressed like freddy krueger to celebrate
the occasion
what it's halloween relax or what if you
uh went to identify a relative's remains
at the the coroner's office and the
woman there
is dressed like a sexy vampire it's just
it's not appropriate for the occasion
and i would say costumes really are
never appropriate for adults it never
really works but especially not in a
professional context though i also have
to say
the fact that organ has literal clowns
running their pandemic response
does not surprise me at all okay number
five here's another
um addition to everyone's favorite genre
of
tick-tock videos that would be the genre
of
women having mental breakdowns on camera
over news events
a lot of these usually this is done in
the car which i think actually explains
a lot by the way about women drivers
that this is where they do their their
this is this is where they have their
emotional collapses
um that doesn't surprise me a lot either
but
here's something a little bit different
this is a mental breakdown in the
bathtub
uh this is a few days old but it's still
good stuff still worth playing here it
is check it out
don't mind me i'm in the bath but
while i've been here i got a
notification
that that uh
amy cody parent was
officially converted to the supreme
court
i didn't think i would be this affected
by it
but i'm scared i'm scared for me
other women people
who need help everyone except
white men so um
please vote next week let's try to
do something you know i see videos like
this and there's this hopeful part of me
that says this has to be parody it has
to be a joke and maybe it is i don't
know
there's obviously planning and forth
forethought and and
editing even that goes into this why
would someone do this
except as a joke you're crying in a
bathtub that's humiliating
this is a humiliating embarrassing
moment in your life
why would you intentionally document it
and spread it online for others to see
if i ever cried at a bathtub if i ever
took a bath
at all i would be embarrassed but if i
was
crying in a bathtub um
i think the last thing i would ever want
to do is tell everybody about it
it would be a shameful moment that i
would keep locked inside myself
for my entire life never to be spoken of
to anyone ever
so why are you putting your own
embarrassing
eminently mockable moments online this
is what people do on tick tock it's sort
of like a form of
of self cyber bullying they're cyber
bullying themselves
by putting this stuff out there it's
like if you peed your pants and then
immediately pulled out your phone and
did a live stream hey guys uh so
just wanna let you know i just peed my
pants um yeah a lot of pee just all over
the pants just
pretty embarrassing thought i should let
you know okay see you later bye
i don't understand the point i don't see
why you would do that um and but we ask
who would do this except to be funny
well the answer is narcissists
narcissists who think that every moment
of their lives
needs to be out there and observed by
everyone who think that everything they
do
and everything they think and say and
feel is profound and important and
worthy of attention uh who think that
every moment of their lives every event
is is is nothing more than an
opportunity to gain more attention
for themselves those are the kinds of
people who do this
just total narcissists and there are a
lot of those out there and so there are
a lot of these types of videos
number six uh we'll do a bonus number
six here finally bonus content i want to
show you a video made by some friends of
ours uh i think this
kind of shows you what we're up against
ch check it out
said you can give me anything
what you looking for man this ain't a
typical request
look bro i can get whatever you need
guns drugs women
you a gambling man you like that hard
stuff you need somebody to go away
look you got cash i make things happen
[Music]
baby parts
what'd you say you heard me unborn human
baby parts sickle
i thought you can get anything what'd it
look like to you
planned parenthood
you know it's a joke but it's it's not
at the same time this is what planned
parenthood does and
was caught doing and yet half a billion
dollars
half a billion dollars every year
from the taxpayer and it does
almost still shock me almost
that these people were caught on tape
and the tapes are still there you can
see them on youtube selling human body
parts
the body parts of babies on tape
laughing about it
we saw these videos not deceptively
edited by the way that's a myth that's a
lie
planned parenthood did their own
forensic analysis of those tapes
that were done by dave deliden in the
center for medical progress and they
themselves admitted that they were not
substantially edited
in any way that's manipulative or
deceptive they admitted that in their
own report
go look that up too and so this is all
on tape and yet uh
nobody talks about it anymore like it
never happened
and still the half a billion dollars
keeps funneling
every year from your pockets
into theirs with no sign of stopping if
it didn't stop with a democrat congress
or
rather a republican congress and a
republican president it's not ever gonna
stop
okay let's get to our daily cancellation
today for our daily cancellation i fear
uh i may have trouble containing my
emotions
as we discuss this topic uh this is the
kind of thing i might cry in a bathtub
over
because i have to cancel beard shamers
somehow in the year 2020
beard shaming still exists anti-beard
bigotry is real it's serious it's
perhaps the greatest human rights crisis
of our time you could argue
jack dorsey the supreme leader of
twitter was questioned by
a senate committee yesterday along with
mark zuckerberg
other tech ceos over their censorship of
content on their platforms
now i was planning to talk about the
hearing itself maybe do a cancellation
of jack dorsey
though that does seem unnecessary after
ted cruz had his way with him
let's let's listen a little bit of that
today
i want to focus my questioning on mr
dorsey
and on twitter because of the three
players before us i think twitter's
conduct has by far
been the most egregious
mr dorsey does twitter have the ability
to influence elections no
you don't believe twitter has any
ability to influence elections
no we are one part of a spectrum of
communication challenge that people have
so you're testifying to this committee
right now that that twitter when it
silences people when it censors people
when it blocks political speech
that has no impact on elections people
people have choice of other
communication channels with which
not if they don't hear information if
you don't think you have the power to
influence
elections why do you block anything
uh well we have policies that are
focused on making sure that more voices
on the platform are possible
we see a lot of abuse and harassment
which ends up silencing people and
having them leave from the platform
all right mr dorsey i find your opening
questions your opening answers
absurd on their face yeah so ted cruz
kind of
nails him to the wall there which is
nice to see none of this has anything
to do by the way with the cancellation
really but uh i think it's it's it's
interesting
and so let's listen to so you heard that
let's listen to the next line of
questioning anyway
and then we'll get to the daily
cancellation why did twitter make the
decision to censor the new york post
uh we had a hack materials policy
um when's that policy adopted uh
in 2018 i believe in 2018 go ahead what
was
what was the policy so the policy is
around
limiting the spread of materials uh that
are hacked
um we didn't want twitter to be a
distributor for hack materials
we found that the new york post because
it showed the direct materials
screenshots of the direct materials
and it was unclear how those were
attained that it felt
that it fell under this policy now so in
your view if it's unclear the source of
a document in this instance the new york
post
documented what it said the source was
which it said it was a
a laptop owned by hunter biden that had
been turned into a
repair store so they weren't hiding what
they claim to be the swords
is it is it your position that twitter
when you can't tell the source blocks
blocks press stories no not at all
um we our team made a fast decision
uh the enforcement action however of
blocking urls
both in tweets and uh in dm
in direct messages we believe was
incorrect and we changed it
today the new york post is still blocked
from tweeting
two weeks later yes they have to log
into their account which they can do
at this minute delete the original tweet
which fell
under our original enforcement actions
and they can tweet the exact same
material from the exact same article and
it would go through
right well that's that's nonsense of
course the new york post was still
blocked for days
even though the reason for the block was
admitted to be wrong
but rather than just let them back on
the platform twitter wanted them to
delete the tweet which there was nothing
wrong with uh and didn't violate any
rules
and then post it again none of this
makes any sense
it's also quite beside the point because
i'm not focused on issues like
censorship the first amendment
monopolies big tech manipulation of the
public discourse
uh or anything like that to me the big
issue here is the beard
that jack dorsey was sporting in that
video it was a long
bold elaborate extensive beard
a beard that is not ashamed of itself
not a shame to announce itself to the
world
and though i don't like anything else
about jack dorsey i respect
that beard as i respect all beards
the same cannot be said for much of
social media which spent yesterday
mocking dorsey for his beard saying the
most hateful
and bigoted and frankly hurtful things
and yes it's true that if you wanted to
you could make an argument that dorsey
looks like a homeless wizard or bin
laden's albino cousin or
an out-of-work pirate or a down on his
luck old testament prophet
or the decayed remains of a civil war
general or tom hanks if he'd stayed on
the island for another 45 years
you could make all those arguments you
could say all of that if you wanted to
and many
people have i will not say any of that
though
because i do not condone such insults
because a man has a
constitutional right to grow a beard
and any who exercise that right ought to
be congratulated for that
noble undertaking you want to make fun
of jack dorsey for the nose ring the
nose ring he was also wearing
absolutely that's fine indeed it is your
duty as an american to make fun of men
who wear nose rings
but the beard is off limits a man's
beard is an outward expression
of the masculine light within him each
follicle as it
sprouts forth and reaches for the
sunlight deserves to be loved and
celebrated
for its own sake if you wish to shame a
man for something
beard related shame him for not having
one
shame him for being a grown man with a
schoolboy's chin
beardless men are absurd ridiculous when
i see beardless men i react much like i
react to the sight of a three-legged
dog i sort of gawk and stifle laughter
but then
also i feel pity for this poor wretched
deficient
embarrassing thing and yet many beerless
men have testified before senate
committees without a word of mockery
even yesterday mark zuckerberg
with the smooth face of a large infant
testified
and not one person pointed and laughed
at him this is all backwards
as always my problem is not that we are
mocking people but that we're mocking
the wrong people for the wrong reasons
and it is this upside down and backwards
way of thinking that has led
you could argue to many of the worst
tragedies in recent history
i want you to think about this it has
been over a century since we have had a
president
with facial hair even longer since a
full beard has been in the white house
in the interim there have been two world
wars a cold war a depression multiple
recessions
multiple pandemics thousands of plane
crashes
what is this a coincidence we stop
electing bearded men and suddenly the
world explodes and you don't see a
connection
give me a break don't be ridiculous our
anti-beard bias is literally killing
people how many more have to die
you ask yourself that question in the
meantime beard shaming is canceled
how dare you how dare all of you jack
dorsey does not deserve this treatment
and the very idea that you would heap
abuse on this man
who was a billionaire but evidently
can't afford a comb
that's unconscionable comes can be very
expensive these days
who are you to judge let he without sin
cast the first stone as jesus christ
himself said
and guess what jesus had on his face
i rest my case and we'll leave it there
for today
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio was mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the andrew clavin
show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
clayton